okay I should be live I'm gonna waste no
time and just start a game I should make
sure I'm not streaming from the st.
Louis channel I'm pretty sure I'm
streaming from my channel let me just
double check this before I go any
further
twitch London
[Music]
I'm live on my channel rights
yes okay so I successfully changed the
stream key from earlier
and okay let's play some chess I'm gonna
play a London and we're playing Nathan
we need revenge on Nathan because he
beat me in what is now a famous video on
YouTube and it was devastating
to be fair I was distracted by a very
large group of kids okay so he's playing
when is he going for sure he's somewhat
prepared
he's gonna probably play the Weslie so
line unless he plays just mainline
okay let's swipe it ship t3
would be a bit tricky here
I did suggest queen I mean take a fate
but the the poll suggested otherwise
okay I'm going to take on d6 and play f4
and we're going to play like a stone
wall except it's a good stone wall
because I don't have a bishop on c1
v6 okay let's develop
while hello to everyone in the chat
chest with Kris hello Morris and shield
hello cool guy hello just low FPS I hope
my fps is not too bad
hello hero good to see everyone
whoa what is that that was cool guy
thanks cool guy to the Sun I'm in the
castle eight yeah let's castle
I actually think Nathan just missed a
chance he could have taken and then I
would have had to take with C pawn
because this pawn is tied down to the
spawn and he could have played this I
did this he could do this
that was actually a strong opportunity
but now
okay there's no going back in time 95
looks very pleasant and this is like a
dream stone wall position right like
good pawn structure no darks for a
bishop we need one Queen h4 ideas so he
wants to play this maybe I just play g4
and pawn storm
who is John John is most generous donor
of all time donated like a bunch of
times in a row given they they were all
test donations but still John is debt is
very generous but yeah John is like the
stream labs like test donation things so
don't get too excited
got carried away with giving myself test
donations okay so he plays ninety four
so he has some purpose in life
if I take on you for
it's pawlenty for
I could play this but then he might
track my nights
hmm
I'm thinking I probably should have
played queen bee one to prevent nights
efore again there's no going back in
time until we invent the time machine
then we can go back in time I think I
should probably just continue with
attacking the question is
either way attack and allow f6 like
Queen c2
maybe I will play Queen c2
just put more pressure on on the night
if you plays are five then the spine is
happy I'll just play g5
and okay we both have outposts this line
is a bit misplaced and so is this Bishop
let's reinforce the night
I mean objectively it's probably equal
but I feel like it's slightly more
pleasant for white to play because I
have a good bishop
he has a bad bishop I have more space on
the kingside especially it's up on storm
a bings school guy for the comments what
lecture did they post already forgetting
we had the Nathan video of getting
crushed on me Ches oh and then we have
the double pawns video yeah I was happy
with that one I was really tired when I
gave that lecture and then towards the
end I started losing my voice because I
had the cinnamon latte and the cinnamon
just got stuck it was terrible
okay so g6 I'm gonna go for the pawn
storm further I'm allowing Knight g3 but
then I'll play rook f2
your plan is kingi to rock h1
Isley elites hostile work is not
detecting my stream because I change it
to the st. Louis channel I was wondering
why okay
I'll have to fix that at some points but
now I first have to fix this e-file
tension maybe I can play Queen C Queen
2h 2
when h2 kingi to wreckage one is an idea
and the C file is gonna stay closed cuz
I'll always take with the epon okay real
quick
I apologize for people who want to watch
the game but it's a serious business and
go to streamers
now I have to go to my page see edits
okay my streamer page now I have to
change this back to I am Rosen the last
dream I did was on the st. Louis twitch
channel submits I'll probably have to
message one of the mods to change
everything back
um but before I do that I should push my
H spawn
and now the files guaranteed to open up
because of the tension and I control
when it opens up unless he wants to take
here which he probably doesn't want to
do because you want to play h6 you might
want to play h6
I don't think h6 is a useful move for a
black though I'm gonna play King g2
and I just want to increase pressure
as the center is so closed so the focus
should be on the kingside
so are there any mods on
and I can message
see here oh there is one okay we're
going to go to no joke
um except we want to go to the other tab
so no joke
wait is Lee chest org detecting the
stream oh it is okay I don't have to do
anything
nevermind
I thought when I change it back they
would have to manually adjust the stream
but I guess we chest is just so well
automated that
they don't have to do anything which is
nice
okay so blacks under pressure because I
want to increase tension
one day I'll open the H file
probably the ideal setup is to what is
that why is it why is it doing double
noise
because I have the two things who was
just subscribed I'm singer thanks for
the sub I appreciate that
um I appreciate your message too
there is a slightly new layout
I have a lamp like writing from my face
so there's light
Nathan's still thinking it's a good sign
I desperately need revenge I cannot
allow him to to have the most recent win
realizing there might be another idea
here - never mind I was thinking that h4
was another idea
I'll take with the Knights
- whoop SSB
good to see you on Twitch
like a lot of people find me on YouTube
and then find the twitch channel it's a
nice nice form of discovery Rollo Ryan
long time no see
I kill something something something
good to see you
wait Nathan are you vegan you don't have
cheese on your sandwich
and slightly unacceptable anyway let's
focus on the position this is it's
actually approaching probably some
critical moment I mean what has
everything under control I essentially
control when the aisle will open
I could okay I don't want to take on g6
too soon
I could take on e4 and then play some
position words
Bishop versus goodnight
which is a title of my stream rights the
title suits the position very well
I think I'll start with rook h1 why not
probably a move I should not take too
much time on
and speaking of time I think White has a
lot of time here because what is black
doing
I mean tries to open something up it
still stays closed and then meanwhile
I'll probably just start rearranging my
pieces like maybe my queen goes f3 ok
maybe I can go to h3 and then f3
and then the rook can come to h3 the
other can come to h1
and then or maybe the work can come to
h4 and my queen comes back to h3 I'll
just triple up
and the singer is our real donation as a
test donation the UM singer 20 bucks I
will pay for several Rhonda lattes and
no joke with the sub what is going on
here and how do I fix the sound and go
into properties
um
[Music]
I can fix the sound
yeah I don't think I can fix a sound
cause any time any time anyone serves or
donates isn't me a lot of sound um whoa
so many questions about GM norms and
haircut okay I'm gonna play Queen h3 and
go with the plan he wants to play this
I'll probably play that he plays that
and I just take it
um to
a question from brawl Orion how far am i
from the GM norm well there's the GM
norm and then there's a GM title to get
the GM title I need three norms and a
rating of 2500 which is very far away
so I'm yeah I'm nowhere close I was
close to
oh gosh the sound okay I'm gonna go and
change things and just mute everything
one bit whoever you are let's play three
I do apologize for the
technical things
there's a sound
0%
options
I feel like a 6%
scriber is going to be very quiet
donations will I won't change uh and
then bits will go down too
okay
save settings
wait I cheered I gave a test donation
oops
I'm so confused right now there we go
about that
this is complicated
what okay i muted i'm still up on time i
don't know how i'm up on time
i'm gonna continue with the plan except
now okay i see his plan of playing this
in this because now this pawn is
defended so this is maybe a time to
calculate where if I play Queen f3 he
plays that I play this he plays that I
ignore him he takes I take looks really
strong
do it
go here here thank you fishing for the
follow
Quinn are three
because he's just a tat he's just
attacking my pawns I'm attacking his
King
things are more valuable than pawns
right
Nathan giving a line in the chat but
this is rated I shouldn't look at the
line don't want any unfair assistance
hello Manos good to see you -
I'll scroll up and look at the questions
after this game but let's start by
doubling up on each file and and
attempting to break through
you
the whole idea when I get the rook to h1
if I can take and he takes and I take
and he takes and I take and he takes
I'll have Knight take g6 in the end and
I take his queen it's a lot of taking
now the question is do I take on B for
first and do even more taking
you
as it is attempting to open the a file
wait a minute
I'm spotting something fishy and I'm
thinking this rook is overworked and the
king is overworked
they're both defending this thing on h8
so if I take em black takes and I take
if the king takes AI for Kim if the rook
takes I win the bishop so let's take on
g6
do I take on a B for first no let's take
on g6 and that white should be winning
material
I guess he could take here and then his
whole kingside will far fall apart
probably
assuming this is working for a white
this is going to be very sweet revenge
I should probably keep calculating if he
takes on c3
who you plays Bishop eh that's a good
sign
whenever they play it passively it's a
good sign because now I can continue
queen h5 rat of Queen h6
I can also just play this
yeah let's do that it's just very strong
threat
I do think Bishop e8 is too passive but
I think black was in trouble anyway
a semi-open c-51 an attack there are
three attackers against my seat pond
and sold me upon
you're I'm threatening to win the Queen
okay so he takes with the bishop
as its playable
if I take
well I take the bishop we could trade a
bunch
hmm
you
you
you
I'm thinking I should just take the
night's because my bishops not doing
anything
and I can get my Queens age for it very
easily you can get this Bishop to a5
I defend the pawn she wins a three pawn
maybe I take care first
I have to be a little bit careful
you
I have another idea - okay I'm gonna
start by taking on before I'm gonna play
rook h6 completely different idea which
I have not vocalized because I I'm
pretty sure Nathan is watching Nathan
still in the chat so 99% sure he's
listening with volume
and we'll see how this transpires
you
I'm holding off on answering questions
or interacting with the chat until this
game finishes because I need to take
this seriously
to get revenge I'm not even looking at
the chat okay so he takes on c3
my idea wait maybe I shouldn't say that
idea first I should just move I have a
few ideas too
you
this is actually very complex
you
[Music]
you
it's very complex there's so many crazy
lines what is going on here
you
you
have a feeling this should be good
enough it looks risky but
okay he's still the one under pressure
I have a gun is a pawn
you
pretty sure my gun is more powerful than
his pawn
you
I like the time situation too if he just
wants to keep thinking for about 20 more
seconds that would be nice
but there is a five-second comment so
well he takes on its on g5 did not see
that coming
I guess it's playable I mean I have a
number of options here
because I don't have to take I like I
could play this even
keep all the pressure
could take
and you'll go ahead and play this
because he I don't think he would see
this coming
and now he has 15 seconds left and he's
pinned
Ethan saying we should go oversea - in
that position
see - in this position interesting
see - I kind of forgot about it but I
assume I can just take
attacking the Queen if he promotes I
just take his queen and then his other
queen is still attacked and then if he
plays
this I can take
I'm threatening this
should be good enough
I still have more time than him this
other queen is hanging his nice hanging
and this rooks hanging his other exit
act yes six seconds left
see that good thing I'm up to pieces at
the end of this variation
because he could win this pond
about together an outpost
and not just any outpost this is a
monster outpost
the funny thing is if he plays rook g3
king of two traps a rook
brooke has no squares I'm so sorry
Nathan
but this is uh this is very sweet
revenge okay
I don't think there's any dirty flagging
good game Nathan I was slightly
stressful but also very sweet
if we go back yeah there was
there is definitely complications ego
let's turn off stock fish sable no naval
in line notation disable stock fish
there were complications because
he does breakthrough on the queenside
and
in many cases if he gets something to
the second-ranked my King has very
little shelter so he was saying see to
all just glanced at the previous Mastiff
messages briefly I don't know if I
missed anything too important a Peters
fiddler no I did not get a haircut I'm
about to get a haircut I have to look up
where the barbers are in this area I'm
capturing desktop audio and I have it as
audio capture I'm bad with audio but now
if anyone okay no one's cheered or
donated or subscribed since since I
changed the sound but it should be
better now ah Eric with three exclams
hello - - ah good to see you
long time no see by the way
a cheer from hero thanks hero
how can I get the next Magnus stream
front page on Twitch
[Music]
oh that was from okay that was from no
joke to not us okay
uh wait who's white noise dude white
noise white noise with a thousand bits
out of nowhere and Nathan gamertag
Nathan gifted a sub to chess gamertag
thank you everyone for such generosity
let's quickly try and analyze this
position c2 is not under my radar
probably should have been because the
pawn is threatening to promote but I
assume it's very similar that I could
just take and I'm keeping the initiative
because now the threat is to take on
each seven the queen is attacked if he
Queens it's very similar to what
happened in the game his queen would
still be hanging and this rook is
hanging and this is attacked and this is
attacked so
yeah I'm not sure
where things went wrong maybe there's
some better way of defending
maybe Bishop eh should be played much
sooner
and then like Bishop s7 and make a
turtle butt
earlier in the game
I thought that six could be played a bit
more a bit more challenging
and then even earlier
should have just been aware of the
bishops unleashed here and I should have
like queen bee one or even Queen f3 just
to prevent 94
anyway wait Nathan are you coming to st.
Louis I see something about that or I
was probably just hallucinating as you
have school yeah
but if you're in the Illinois you can
come to st. Louis for just a couple of
days very easy trip
railroad 80 yeah I did trip on the H
file
play 25 rook h2
yeah that's possible rook h2 and then
rook a h1
but I didn't want my queen leading the
battery maybe it was yeah maybe it was
more time efficient because if I do go
for that and he goes for the minority
attack I could probably get away with
just taking the rook and then I'm
threatening work eight seven mates I
didn't think that deeply or that
effectively
I just yeah I have this built-in like
mechanism where I don't want a queen
leading a triple battery but yeah it was
probably
and hindsight that was probably the best
approach is so much faster okay we'll
play another game
I do have a friend here with me
give me a random number between one and
seven uno dos tres cuatro
I don't think yeah I haven't played this
guy before
from Italy
Oh Nurik Oh onion okay
looking at his name just wants me to
wanst what am I trying to say I just
want to cry looking at his name anyway
we have it ready
I'm gonna play a six and go for do I
wanna play another huge Edie let's spice
it up let's play Queen's Indian I've not
played the Queen's in you know a long
time at least on stream back Cloney
thanks for the follow
this guy play the game before oh he has
it's not a slow game so he plays g3 I'm
gonna play this
and then c5
this is a it's a
playable line and somewhat of a sideline
slightly more rare than main lines
Nathan with a dollar donation
Thank You Nathan
so I I think the last time I played this
line in a tournament
was against fun Whaley in the
Netherlands
and he completely crushed me like he he
took on before and then he played some
amazing positional chess and then the
game was published in American chess
magazine and then I stopped playing the
line
yeah to adjust cool guys comment anyone
who has not seen the st. Louis chess
club you should come to st. Louis
especially if you play chess just a
great place for chess
taking a walk today like right before
sunset walking by the chess King and is
a great like instagram-worthy photo you
see if I can show people
look at that that's just the king
just hall-of-fame they upgraded their
King because the Chess Club had the
world's largest chess piece if she
thinks for the follow until until
somewhere in Germany like beat them by a
few inches so then they got rid of their
chess piece and they got a bigger chest
piece and now they again they have the
world's largest chess piece
and it's so tall it's taller than most
most giraffes or elephants so he finally
okay he finally challenges his Bishop
I'm gonna take and we'll trade a bunch
of things take on d4
and eventually I'll get some kind of
Hedgehog structure I'll take on g2
you
and it's a question how do I continue
because I could play d6 I could play d5
I could play knight c6 I could play
Queen c7
d5 is certainly in the most challenging
move
but then it leads to symmetry which I
don't really want
I mean c7 is playable
I think I'll play Queen c7
just looking at a few lines here like if
he plays might be five I play this at
some point I'll play a six to stop night
b5 and meanwhile I'm tying his night
down to this pawn so we'll probably play
this
plan for completing development is this
and then probably this make use of my my
half open C file
he's been feingold still working in st.
Louis he's in Atlanta he got married he
started his own chess Center
um I don't know the last time he was in
st. Louis maybe he was here last year
he started his chest Center in September
pretty sure he was in st. Louis last
year f3
been Feingold is he's crying about
Heights last move
this f3 he wants to play E for you go
the play d4 right away so I could play
knight c6 and challenges Knights
think about f3 I can't really punish him
for it or can I maybe I can can I play
this
discouraging me for if we trade then I
had this idea
might be a good move
to it just trust my intuition because
this is week
this is undefended this is attacked
twice this is about to be an open file
and to be fair I do have to complete
developments
but you're like there's issues for
whites
Leon yah 81 you saw the same in this
video
that's cool I was really tired when I
gave that lecture because I had a long
day of chess um but I I was happy with
it I feel like the games I showed were
for decent they followed some theme
b3 okay
so he reinforces upon
so one idea is to play e5 but then you
plays Knight b5 move the Queen
other ideas to do this I like rook to
Yeats
I'm trusting my intuition more than
normal many times I would just spend a
lot of time to calculate but
today I'm gonna go with first instincts
because Rick d8 okay there's three
things on the file and they all look so
delicious
probably the thread is just taking
okay now I can take with the night and
now I'm threatening a triple fork and
how is he's offending
as if you play as okay night c4 is a
move
the good move
there's no way this can be good
okay because this is a problem for him
and this is a problem for him the night
is tied down to defending III so I have
a few things for work with here okay so
one of the first ones that come to mind
is b5 but then they take b5 if I check
take take my queen hangs and then both
my works are hanging so next thing that
comes to mind is 'if I've attacking this
knights if the knight moves anywhere
except b5 I'll have Knight f4 to win the
Queen so let's imagine a five-night b5
and then let's say queen c5 if I'm
attacking the knight
I guess you could play Knight c3 there
but that I still went as Queen
of 95 weensy 5 so I have the double
threat of taking the night and playing
Knight f4 to win is Queen
does he defend
I've
just gonna do it I'm not gonna spend too
much energy looking for his defenses
even though that would be probably the
professional thing to do
just going to trust that the tactics are
working
you
you
oh yeah back Cloney if you want to play
me um you can challenge me on me chess
and then I'm just letting Siri determine
my fate
so I'm gonna play as many games as it
takes for me to get tired that's the
goal
for good to see you
long time going to see
Joker TF
impersonating men find gold
Leonia 81 thank you thank you for the
feedback
why not be 5 and then 93
um yeah if I played b5 first he could
take I could play this he could take I
could win his queen
but then humans my queen and white would
be winning material there
so I'm gonna try and refrain from
looking at lines until later
um in the meantime I'll go back I'll see
if I missed any questions but he moves
he five
he plays efore chess worm thanks for the
follow
I was aware of e4 I just assumed it
should not be working for some reason
and that reason might be Knights III
that's a weird move manas thanks for the
host I'm gonna turn off sound for
hosting
no I don't want a test host
Stream Labs
okay let's focus Knight c3
the Queen moves and then wherever it
moves I take his Knights
I see three I guess he could no he can't
do this because I take okay I'm playing
Knight c3 I think black is just winning
a piece
Jimmy thanks for the follow
I'm pretty sure
this should just be over because once I
take is night my pond offends my Knights
then it's an outpost
happy 5 on the horizon and then I'll
complete development
why not knight c6 996 at what points
I'd see six I don't think makes any
sense in this position
for into earlier
sometimes if you have a question about a
move give the move number is that it's
just more specific ah but it is my move
let's take as Knights
this night is so strong because he can't
access to you one so he can't really
pressure my pawn
Skype I'll check the messages I'll check
my messages after the stream I'm still
very behind on responding to messages
because this week has been so hectic
like today was my off day I spent um
only half the day still giving lessons
I will I will slowly but surely get
through my messages
I mean take c4
waitwhat I mean takes you for the the
night guards or the pawn is guarding the
night
hello to more people hello phenom monkey
and hello grafica good to see you guys
back
there's never an off day in the chest
world that's very true
it's hard to find the balance between
chess and non chests
you
daily dreams thank you for the follow
at some point we'll have to start some
countdown two to three thousand rupees
thanks for the sub
preciate all the love so he plays rook
d1 after I said he can't access to you
one so let's take the rook and let's do
this
I think you can get away with this move
you
but black is up a rope here
winn-dixie foreign move 15 wait a minute
fifteen
I'd even consider that I think it's just
a trade though I could take on c4 or
take here King here take take
maybe it's a positional approach I do
damage his pawn structure but I don't
want any material and I'm sure he would
be
surviving and whites doing completely
fine there I'm still underdeveloped
Labatt's
thank you for the follow okay so it's my
move let's finish this game quickly can
I win material okay I guess I can trade
Queens
I'll play 96
and put the rook in the game
this is uh okay this is a this is a
rapid game 15 plus 10 is rapid
so casual must be or classical must be
very slow then let's take upon play d3
my deep on looks overextended but it
will be supported by my knight and my
pawn will support my knight
life is good
so what's a the line between classical
and rapid
like what's the quickest cut the
quickest classical game be curious
you
Jimmy Ackerman first time seeing me live
I guess it would be weird like seeing
the chat for the first time
or maybe it's always weird just seeing
the chat
no offense chat
[Music]
okay I have one job and the one job is
not to get back rank maiden mission
accomplished
oh he could take on d3 with tactics
I trade
hmm
so the quickest way to win this is
probably by making Oh probably by him
resigning okay a good game onion
[Music]
yeah it was a relatively equal position
from from out of the opening
I think the better way to play this is
to take the bishop
if you want to know how to play this
line you can Google bond Whaley Eric
Rosen
where is it line in probably
wait but
oh that doesn't have the game maybe
chess games
[Music]
I don't know where to find it if you
have an issue of the American chess
magazine it was from a couple years ago
fun fact my chess TV is broken we have
27 games there should be like over 200
it's probably a good thing but can't
prepare for me
new game new opponents
give me a random number between 1 and 14
211 in Spanish
we
tres cuatro Cinco seis siete Ocho Nueve
Diez
Oh si chest poems good luck
Arvind SP thanks for the follow we're
playing chess problems 10 plus zero and
this is rated
is 1343
[Music]
it's a cheer Bravo Ryan
did I just play brawl Orion good game if
I just played you
yeah I would
now I'm
I'm kind of motivated to find that
family game because I think it would
provide you value of how to crush me in
that line okay this guy's playing a
London
I'm just gonna play my normal d5 just do
the usual stuff
he's so scared each three creating so
much lift for the bishop
when they play h3 it's um it's a signal
to be aggressive
because I think h3 is just a waste of
tempo let's play 96 I want to play e5
I guess he could play this
and I can't play you five
okay he's letting me play e5 this is
nice
get to do this too often as black just
get the pawns in the center like this
you
I should make one thing clear for my
student and further the students that I
teach I don't force them to play the
London Eye just I go over openings they
want to learn but I'll give them
recommendations to
and a lot of my students do end up
playing the London because I I do like
to recommend it refika appreciate the
sub
so now he's threatening to win upon
I could defend when a for squint a 5
lead to anything Knight c3 probably not
because you can weigh the minutes
let's slow down Queen a five-night c3 is
forced d4 you could take on c6 you could
take there but I'm winning the night
so it's like a pretty
for a tactic
you
okay let's try and answer some questions
in the chat
seeing some questions what level do I
teach I teach all levels most of my
students
probably ranged between like 1200 to
1800
recently I've been teaching a lot of
students who play like exclusively
online and don't really play over the
board chess which is interesting there's
a lot of players like that nowadays but
I do teach all levels and all ages when
I'm busy sometimes it's harder to take
on new students but I usually try my
best
let's take the bishop his Knights opened
Lillith okay so you watch my London
video that's nice I do not play
caro-kann even though it's sometimes
resembles some kind of London structure
um
I just never got into
okay
you like it but you have trouble against
advance variation
yeah it's hard to play with the space
deficits
but carol connivance variation it's
playable you just have to kind of know
theory from what I assume but I'm
probably not the person to ask about
Carroll County
it's just one of those things where okay
if you're looking to play caro-kann take
a look at the games of like of Karpov
maybe even though Sam Shanklin he's been
playing it recently see how they deal
with those lines
okay let's trade bishops
I'm up a piece for two pawns
you
that's response to d4
you said kf6 but I think you mean Knight
f6 and then I I think you mean Knight f3
I usually play d5 there as black
also payee 6c 5 so a bunch of moves I
think there's one best response
but
I prefer classical chess which involves
playing d5
and Hiro agrees that's nice I would play
d5 because if they play a London I would
be happy or if they play Bishop g5 I
would be even more happy than ie 4 is
already they'd be slightly better for
black
you
is Noteboom very
Asian good this Noteboom
I should know what the Noteboom is
that's where you got pawns unlike be
four and a-five is black
um and like Sokolov for the book about
it right
okay I'm gonna quickly google Sokolov
Noteboom hero the buck right
Amazon
you
never minds maybe I'm wrong
the book on the Noteboom maybe it was
just some other variation I'm getting
confused
okay anyway focusing on this game I like
blocks position there's a pin I'm up a
piece I could win a pawn I could control
the file let's control the file and then
play rook d2 should be the quickest path
to victory
imagining Queenie one runty to rook t1
and then Bishop take you to
this is hard to stop
you
what do i playing as Alec I'm
I like to play mainline I mean I could I
could start answering questions if you
guys would like
um
again sallekhana I recommend
I can recommend a few things you can
play e5 95 and then like d4 Knight f3 or
you could start with Knight c3 I'll move
to
the problem is if you start with Knight
c3 on move to you could walk into be
five and then you have to be prepared
for some kind of like
whatever Vienna or four nights I'm going
to take on b2
now there's three attackers on e two
and really no way for a white to the
fens
side position
hmm I could show a really funny line in
alkyne
remind me after this game ends and then
all
I look forward to showing it
okay if you think if you can't find the
van wheelie game I have another laptop
open right now let me see if it's in my
files
on Whaley
urghhh my database
you
so quickest made here can I take
he takes discovery check probably not
you
wait rook b8 is a is a concern
you
okay I see a solution I'm gonna take on
you two he's going to play here and then
I take take and rook d1 and I won't be
up to pieces
you
okay
let's do a search
I'm pretty sure that getting the bun
Whalley game was broadcast
not sure if it was on a website where it
would get saved
you
okay there's no increment so he's gonna
play on it's not gonna last too long
hundred viewers
what a milestone thank you everyone for
watching
I don't know how long I've been
streaming feels like a long time though
instead of asking questions how about
learning a new opening
waitwhat
instead of answering questions it
learned a new opening I'm always down to
learn a new opening
okay he wants to play repeats
time to castle never too late to castle
now the goal in this position is to meet
as quickly as possible so that's
probably going to involve
optimizing my pieces saving my bishop
I'm imagining some mate like this
kind of a faraway dream but maybe it's
possible now the h3 is not a serious
move and it deserves a question mark
um England gambits
no I don't think so I play c5 Knight c6
Queen b6
what is LSB
supper thanks for the follow
yeah if only rooks could move like this
as they could in bughouse you just have
to be off the board
and let's start with this
the other amazing idea is to put them
down in g3 somehow provoke f3 get an
outpost and then made on h1
okay now everything changes let's put
them on g4
the goal is to meet him before he flags
but that might be difficult esta Chen
good to see you yeah I'm probably going
to turn this into a Q&A stream after
this game
unless some or at least four is
something like some short time and then
maybe all rubber to playing games but
there are some interesting questions so
and I want to provide value okay I have
a discovered check let's do this ooh
fork but he can play G for ever mind
okay I win the rook good game chess
poems but did he do wrong that game
oh yeah he gave me the center h3 is the
first slow move now the move you should
play too early in the London if you're
scared of Knight h5 then you can play e3
and then you prevent not h5 and then you
focus on developing even here III would
be better and then here when I want to
play e5 Knight f3 would be better and
then this is a classic trap
okay
for the longest time how to read chess
books some chess books if you read the
introduction they tell you how to read
them not all of them but at least some
of them that I'm aware of
will tell you how to approach them
yeah so I found the van Whaley game that
I was referring to
I could add both of them missus
yeah give me one moment I'm gonna open
up a new study
we can you study
q and a
it's completely public the
chapter will be Alekhine because that's
the thing I'm most excited to show Jimmy
Ackerman I should keep playing games I'm
gonna answer a couple questions and I'll
probably go and play some games
um the first thing I wanted to show in
alkyne this is something I used to play
a lot in blitz is to play Knight c3
black plays t5 and then I can play e5
and then black will usually play d4
tick tick and now okay key move handi
for
and the idea is after pawn take be too
g7 queen queen
positions probably about equal but it's
fun to play in blitz unless it's over
the board and you can't find the Queens
and you have to like run around the
tournament hall looking for Queens but
then what's even cooler is let's say
block takes a pawn white takes this pawn
a key idea for both sides is to push the
pass pawns so I've had games where white
makes another queen in black makes
another Queen and then it's just six
Queens on the board
this happened at all database me chess
no
position has happened
um Queens III check
these people are so boring they just
trade Queens right away queen c6
I like this game what the game okay so
that's a cool line if you just want to
be be weird and mess around but it's
completely playable it's just probably
equal I guess we can call it the Four
Queens variation but if you want
something more serious against the
Alekhine I can recommend this and then
after d69 a three here this is usually
what happens
I guess it requires some knowledge but I
can take with either pawn
um I don't think matters let's say black
takes with this pawn here here have your
if you're looking to take this seriously
I recommend a setup where white plays b3
Bishop b2 92 and then d4 is very well
defended c4 is defended
variations can keep going like bishop
can we can just follow opening explorer
let's say b3 here there should be seven
castle castle there should be two Bishop
f6 Knight bTW two
um for some reason black is scoring well
here I thought why this supposed to be
good h3 Bishop h5 perky 1
I think it's a comfortable position for
whites there's ideas of night f1 night
g3 if black ever plays d5 white can play
c5
there's also ideas of Bishops III and b4
just expand on the queenside so that's
what I do but but yeah I think Alekhine
should not be the most of your worries
another line I can recommend if you know
your opponent will play d5 is simply to
take take and Bishop c4
and then e 6 or C 6 will likely be
played and then Queen f3 x e6 Queen f3
and I think this leads to a slight
advantage for for whites
anyway did I miss anything else I was
gonna go on give me one moment I'm gonna
copy this game
this won't be on stream because I'm
using my their laptop thank you for the
follow our burritos let's go to leech s
I'm a lord
who
I'm gonna go to study
I studies
No
done under my secret account I'm out
amen
you
this will just take a moment
you
okay finally now add a chapter
okay whoever I played before I think it
was brawl Orion I don't know if he's
still watching
but brawler Ryan if you're still in the
chats I just added the Vaughn Whaley
game to the study so you're welcome to
take a look at it there's a line where I
was playing black and he just he's so
good at chess he knew exactly what to do
Queen d3 very strong move and the c-4
idea at some point please yeah he
eventually play d4 and he just
understood this position better than me
like I wanted to play e5 and control c5
but then he was just super solid knife
f5 knife t5 at some point I just ran out
of moves
kept optimizing his pieces and then II
six was weak I couldn't defend 96 except
I defended with neither fate but then he
played 93 so let's such a monster move
threatening the triple for threatening
the double fork and yeah that's how you
made me cry
you
anyway
were there any other questions
there are any questions
wait I have wait there's a question from
Ethan asking if I'm going to continue
improve my chess improve at chess series
die start a series
I would like to start a series but I
don't know he's talking about
if I do start a series it will probably
be on openings I might just start a Q&A
series just for YouTube or something
and then just get questions for people
anyway
what
singeing okay for a 1500 player
focusing the time on focus on what
you're passionate about and it's a
matter of understanding yourself to like
it's understand it's a matter of
understanding how you learn best if you
learn best by reading books and read
books if you learn best by watching
videos and watch videos um but this can
vary from player to players so I there's
not one thing I recommend focusing your
time line also white noise thank you so
much for the thousand bits again so
generous have no idea who this is this
is a new name until today but I do
appreciate that
title kind of a pun there is no pun
intended with the title there's only a
night intended
book suggests on opening theory I don't
really recommend books for openings
unless like there's a specific opening
you want to learn then there's certain
books which are very good for like
repertories or specific openings but if
you're looking for a book on openings
you first have to identify what you want
to learn and then do the research on
what book to get
for openings I just recommend this thing
opening Explorer but I would guess using
using this in conjunction with a book is
probably one of the most effective ways
to learn openings and then save
everything to elite chess study I'm
actually giving a lecture the st. Louis
Chess Club tomorrow where I'm probably
just going to show like do a lecture on
on how to show people how to effectively
use elite chess tools because one of
those things that maybe isn't the most
intuitive I think people would be able
to to benefit from
how do you memorize openings
possible or just review
also just experience the best way to
memorize openings by playing them in
your own games and then going over those
games and then reviewing them and then
that's usually the way at least for me
that's the way they SiC the best is by
by playing them and then going over the
game analyzing them deeper and also
understanding each move if you're just
purely trying to remember eyes and moves
it can be very difficult but if you
understand the purpose behind each move
then you can put yourself in a situation
where even if you forget you can kind of
figure out what to do based on the
position and I think that's a really
important approach I think Anand said
that or something where
when it comes especially at like the
highest levels when it comes to
memorizing so many things you just have
to understand the position rather than
just crown moves down your down your
throat
what I consider playing arena Kings I
would yeah I would love to play arena
kings I just don't know when they are um
I lost the link which like had the
schedule I don't know where to find it
um and I don't know if it conflicts with
like my my normal work hours but I would
play if if I was more well prepared
please let me know in discord like when
arena Kings is and then I'll make an
effort to play
you're stuck in 1500 in blitz how to
improve play slower chess play slower
chess and then come back to blitz and
then sometimes getting better at chess
as a matter of of understanding the true
value behind each move and I think at
least for me when I play slower chess
and then switch to blitz my blitz games
just become stronger but okay if you're
stuck in anything it's matter about
doing something different and then
seeing what actually can help you make
the change in what doesn't help you make
the change
what's my discord channel moobot just
shared the link which is nice
if you're bad in the slower chess um
practice you have to lose a lot of games
so you get good
I've probably lost more games and most
of the people watching combined
it takes a lot of losing to get good at
anything ok let's play another game this
is a short Q&A
one more game after midnight
give me a random number between 1 and 12
I'll count I'll count backwards this
time Doh seance 80s
Taco now I'm hungry for tacos
ooh place across the streets open 24
hours I'm pretty sure they have tacos
sounds good actually okay let's play
Sicilian he's 1900
from the USA
um I'm gonna play a more aggressively
than normal to play this Knight f6 if he
plays a knight c3 I'll play knight c6
the four Knights with a six
you plays Bishop t3 Bishop d3 is not the
main move
cause now he actually has to do
something about this night on g4
and if you trades unhappy
this
if you play c3 I'm also happy then this
night can't go to c3
ninety-two
looks very passive
I'm just gonna develop
my intuition
you
you
you
I like this position and good
development I'm also wondering
did he already just mess up really badly
go completely insane with this move
this I do this
and he's in trouble
he's in big trouble
how does he defend this
it's a problem when the Knights on e -
it's not controlling some key squares
and in this line
I think White's just
not only just losing a pawn but just
losing a lot of material
at least exchange
brawler Ryan goodbye
did he leave oh he left sorry to see him
go
it's another thing if you're stuck and
you only play online I recommend playing
over the board I think it's it's a
completely different ballgame on than
online and can help help you improve
your over overall chess if you play over
the board
anyway I'm happy with the situation
bonds our attacks one point is attacked
with and being Bishop III what a sad
move
I think I can take with the bishop
take with Bishop take with nine Queen D
to take with check out two pawns
it's for an end
you
you
stuff
not gonna pre-move night I take G too
even though it's going to be the next
move
so here's a few options with the king
Oh
we're pretty depressing
in some cases I might like to play this
move
kingi one queen bee six
attacking this threatening either this
or this
against these two moves I probably have
to play this
you
but I mean over the board tournament or
with club members any either one over
the board tournament I think is the best
way to learn is this like the most
serious where you're like there's the
most pressure on the line and you have
the most time to think compared to other
types of games
okay I'm gonna play nice for
now there's many ideas for
black involved in Queen b6 or we not six
I just want the chase that came back to
you once so I can play that of three
although the main goals avocado post
thanks for the follow I bought a couple
avocados avocados are the best
you
okay so I'm up to pawns
King is safer but I'm less developed III
that's suspicious
I'm just gonna play the first move that
comes to mind
it has a threat
and if he tries to run he can't hide
Cairo's
and it's really late
sometimes lose winning positions if
you're in time trouble
it's very common time is a factor in
chess you could have like a position
where you're up a queen but if you have
a minute left
it's not easy
evaluate the value of bullets
all it is a different animal
I don't think it should be grouped in
the category of like serious chess well
there's definitely elements of bullets
where
oh no it's some
where it can be useful talent like
tactical sharpness and how to
recognition opening preparation
requires getting to a certain level
okay so I would like to play this
even this
I'm okay with trading Queens start with
this
I'm expecting Queen f4 and
I'll be up to ponds
I can trade everything
you
you
I mean I will admit I probably enjoy
bullet the most fast-paced --mess and
it's easy to fire people
okay so you please clean up for
you
I mean I wanted to win quickly but
I just might win slowly and solidly
you
you
I'm gonna play Knight here provoke
Queens I got six
there's a few ideas first idea my Kings
going to go to e7
if he plays ip5 Keeney seven
second idea
I'm going to play h5 and a g4
host
third idea on the play a 6 B 5 and
develop my bishop
position looks solid
my biggest weakness is a square but
after Keaney 7:00
everything should be okay
a five
start with this
okay for he wants to play a five
I can't easily play this
if I play b6 a five could be annoying
so now I think the goal is to do this
and then just avoid moving the b-pawn
you
you
there's still many ways to improve the
position
it's a bit stuck like I'm not sure what
his plan is he had gained space it
should be 5 ok by age 5
my bishop on c8 is the worst piece but
maybe at some point I'll just trade it
off
I want to focus on improving my night
first
each three
oh do not want that
nature of switching windows
dangerous
okay let's go for this
yeah I'm just gonna trade
the solid
you
now Bishop c6
now if he takes on c6 I take back with
pawn and I would win the game of Connect
four
it doesn't take on c6 maybe I'll play h4
work h5
you
maybe first rook seats
you
and why it's a bit tied down this is 90
that's tied down to the bishop
this night is kind of tied down to other
nights rook d2 makes a lot of sense
probably player updates
Oh player kd1
and then they'll probably play a six
unless he plays a sex
se6 will trade on c6
the C files nice for black
I would like to someday double up
Bishop a4
you
I'm just curious what he'll do I'm gonna
play h4 give him a move
he's gonna do here
if you like he's almost until our
everything just seems stuck
III okay that's a move
okay now I'll take on a four
I think I would like to play this move
attack is pond
and if he plays b4 it gives me the c-4
square
if he doesn't play before I just went
upon
this is defended
everything is defended for the most
parts
waitwhat I just drop a rook
what
there's a blind spot
drop a rook like that I just didn't see
Knight takes e5
oops
okay
well that's not good I'm down a rook
it's such a good position to
oh that's so sad
what to do
fatigue tiredness and
another pawn or two pawns
man
got to relaxed
that's really bad
that was really bad
so okay how do I create the most chances
and not break anything in this room
you
I'm sorry with rook c8
you
this is really bad
I do still have a good night
maybe two good nights
he's playing solidly let's play rock c6
and not much has changed if we compare
this position to a move ago uh huh huh I
played I played both rooks to c6 and
they merged into one rook
now he plays 94 now I'm in trouble
let's retreat
you
so there's still a few factors which
give me hope doctor number one is time
you
I think that's it
have much hope beyond that
see for with a move
you
run with the king
I would love to take on Seaforth the
rook
more pieces
okay
this looks really wrong but I'm gonna go
for this move
right
I was about to consider rook c5
to attack the a pawn
then he can take me
you
you
you
why didn't he do night 87 I think you
mean they take b7u codified night 87
that would have been a good move
but he's being solid and thank you
Coco for the follow
you
he wants to do this and trade
I would rather not trade
you
you
you
all I want to do is attack something
that's not defended mission accomplished
and the beautiful thing is there
in piles
except the G file but I have a outpost
on g5 I think they call this a four-post
Thank You Freyr for the follow yeah a
four-post is when there's a pollen
defending a minor piece which blocks an
open file so as his extra rook can't
really penetrate and now I'm attacking
upon but more importantly
this thing
I'm avoiding trying to avoid saying the
thing that's going to win me the game
because he might be watching
to trade I don't want to trade
so retreats
kinda sad move
what else to do I can do this
feather
yeah I have to keep the pawn defended
you
nights are tricky thanks are very tricky
he wants to trade again so I could take
and then work him
that's attractive - I want to trade to
win material probably
you
even though it might simplify winning
material here and now I'm only down the
exchange as are equal Aipom structure is
ridiculous
but it could be worse
he could have taken one be seven at
earlier position
okay so now I'm going to retreat
attack something
I don't think I care about this pawn
anymore
you
okay
this is a move I wanted to play early at
which I did play earlier which one the
rook but now it makes sense
check him
check them
now he has to the site as we take my
pawn where does he run away
he takes upon
now I have neither faiths now I don't
think he can stop mate this is beautiful
I have a mating attack
oh maybe he could stop mates but he's
losing material he could play some crazy
move but black is now winning
cuz I have 96 friends
on 96 still threatening me than one I
turned around really quickly
with a miracle
maybe he's also falling asleep
or maybe he's just
tacos
so now the goal is to win win this
without messing up again I would like to
win this by meeting him somehow
but that might be difficult I don't want
to trade rooks let's go back
keep the Kinkel off
euro with a hundred bits thanks hero
thanks Mingo for the follow
it's not a comeback yet until I actually
win this
as I did come back I'm I went from being
down a truck now I'm up in tights
look things can change really
quickly this is like Jenga like one
wrong move in Jenga the whole tower
falls down
what to do
I can do this
I still want to play 9f8 now the plan is
to do this is this horse king h5 and
somehow meet him
or flag him
you
you
you
you
chief I was funny because it's Chuck and
then it's Chuck again
you
but what to do
an attack upon
which pawn may be this pawn
than this pawn
and check again
check again now I'm beginning to win
pawns
I was playing Jenga the other day some
very strong GMS but I'm not a title
Jenga player
do they give titles in Jenga I'm sure
there's Jenga tournaments look it up
okay let's push up on
you
oh I forgot about b7
too late
I'm more focused on mating the Kings
somehow
is that possible
[Music]
because there's a few different mating
ideas but it might be too slow
let's start with Knight e5 because it
slows down c6
slow him down even more
[Music]
you
going for the kill
as I'll take the h3 pollen and then I'll
play Knight g4
he doesn't let me I'll play this
meet
just walk back
she taco was on the verge of winning he
was up a rook but just as tough
I think he just played a bit to safely
or to passively like he should have okay
he should have taken on me seven and he
gave me some material and that was that
yeah this is a nice moment night I fates
King f3 had to be played but then I
would start winning pawns
okay it's time for sleep
thanks Chi taco for for watching
having very heart-wrenching game
you
was the first was estatic earlier oh
yeah Knight g4 this is a nice kind of
trap where if White Castle is Queen h4
there's no defense to both pants
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna audios but
before I do
we will raid everyone watching thanks
people for watching
appreciate the viewership
familiar there's another streamer his
name is Lama Lord and we're gonna raid
him so how this is going to work is that
in just a few seconds I will be ending
the stream and initiating the raid and
what the viewers have to do is join the
raid ok so on the count of three one